each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available uh the first speaker is Aman
um she's a gr student at MIT and she's
uh here with us as an intern this summer
and she'll tell you about evaluating
predicates privately over encrypted
data okay thanks um as we know said I'm
going to talk about evaluating
predicates privately on encrypted data
and this is Joint work with Ela shei and
Brent Waters and appeared in TCC last
year okay so in a traditional encryption
scheme um you can encrypt data under a
public key or a secret key and then only
the owner of the secret key can decrypt
the data so in a sense decryption is
sort of All or Nothing if you have the
secret key you can decrypt the message
and if you don't have the secret key you
can't get any
information but uh in some
applications I don't know now it is um
but in some applications what we want is
more fine grain control over who can
access the data and what can be learned
about the
data so for example you can imagine that
um a user is receiving email encrypted
under her public key and depending on
certain whether certain predicate
predicates are true on the email she
wants to Route the email accordingly
either to her phone or her desktop so if
the subject line includes the word
urgent then um she wants the email to be
routed to her phone and otherwise just
sent to her desktop so the user wants to
be able to um give the server a token
corresponding to these predicates and
let the server test these things but not
learn any other information about the
emails um as another example you can
imagine that a user is um storing her
files encrypted on the cloud and at some
later Point she wants to retrieve all
the files satisfying a certain predicate
for example the category equals work and
the subject line includes
Microsoft
um so predicate encryption is a new
encryption Paradigm which gives us this
more fine grained access
control and okay what is a predicate
encryption scheme look like we have four
algorithms a setup algorithm which gives
us a public key and a secret key um an
encryption algorithm which takes a
public key and a message and returns a
cipher text a generate token algorithm
which takes the secret key and the
description of a predicate and gives us
a token for that predicate so now we
have a query algorithm that takes a
token for a predicate F and a cipher
text for a plain text X and it'll return
one if the predicate F evaluated on X is
true and zero
otherwise so and we can also attach a
payload message to this so that you're
encrypting a message along with X and
the query algorithm will return the
message if the predicate is true and
nothing otherwise but for our
constructions it's simpler to just
consider a predicate only version of
these encryption
schemes so predicate encryption is
related to a lot of other encryption
paradigms which we all um have heard of
for example identity based encryption is
can be seen as a special case of
predicate encryption where the
predicates correspond to equality
testing so an identity based encryption
um each person's public key is a string
corresponding to their identity for for
example their email address you can
encrypt under that public key and only
the person who has um the key for that
string can decrypt the message in
attribute based encryption a user can
receive a capability for a policy over
the attributes um over attributes of
encrypted data and so um a cipher text
can be decrypted if a user has a key for
a policy that is Satisfied by the
attributes of that data but one
important difference is that in ibe and
a the identity and the attributes are
not hidden whereas in predicate
encryption the predicate is encrypted
and
hidden so previous work on U predicate
encryption has looked at this security
notion which we'll call plain text
privacy roughly what this says is that
Cipher text should reveal nothing about
the encrypted plain text beyond what is
revealed by the evaluation of predicates
on
them so a little bit more formally um if
an adversary has tokens for predicates
F1 through FM then a cipher text for a
plain text X should reveal nothing about
X other than what the adversary can
learn by evaluating F1 of X through FM
of
X and there's a whole series of works
that achieve predicate encryption with
PL text priv with you for various
predicates starting with equality
testing and then conjunctions and
disjunctions of equalities and most
recently um the evaluation of in product
queries which was done by cat sah and
Waters in 2008 so one line of research
um looks at expanding the expressiveness
of these schemes and expanding the class
of predicates that we can
achieve but in our work we look at a
different aspect which is the security
definitions and we ask whether in
addition to plain text privacy we can
also achieve predicate privacy so what
do I mean by this um in our example of
encrypted email routing um I said that
if the subject line includes the word
urgent you want the email to be
forwarded to your phone and otherwise
you want it to be forwarded to your
desktop but probably the user wants to
hide these email routing rules from the
server you don't want the server to know
um what predicates you're
testing and in the encrypted file
storage example when you retrieve all
files satisfying some criteria you want
to be able to hide these search criteria
from the
server so it turns out that predicate
privacy is actually difficult to capture
in the public key setting um and the
reason for this is that in the public
key setting the adversary can encrypt
any messages of his choice so for
example in this encrypted file storage
case um if the server has a guess that
the predicate you're searching on is
that the subject includes Microsoft then
the server can just test this by
encrypting a message where the subject
is Microsoft and testing whether the
token uh successfully decrypts that
message so for this reason we focus on
the symmetric key setting and we come up
with a scheme for predicate encryption
that provides predicate privacy in the
symmetric key
setting just check I'm just trying to
see if the you know the deficiency is
inherent isn't it like natural to say
that the attacker outputs X and two
functions f one of two such that f one
of x equals F two of X and then your
example with Microsoft disappears so
entally you will just you know the ATT
and the guessing stage will output
functions F1 F2 and an input X such that
F1 of X is equal to F2 of X right and
then you will encrypt you know you will
produce a cyer Tex for x and
I don't know so if you imagine an
indistinguishability game the adversary
is going to say here are two predicates
that I think I can distinguish tokens
for and now um it's going to get back
tokens for those predicates but it can
right you can encrypt messages that help
you distinguish between the two
predicates okay so so a symmetric key
predicate encryption scheme looks pretty
much like the the public key version but
now our setup algorithm returns just a
secret key you need the secret key to
encrypt a message and to generate a
token you need the secret key and a
description of the predicate and again
the query algorithm is going to return
one or zero depending on the result of
the predicate on the plain
text okay so let's see what the
definition of predicate privacy looks
like a little bit more formally um we're
going to Define this in terms of a game
between an adverse in a challenger and
in the first step the Challenger runs a
setup algorithm generates a secret key
and keeps that to himself then the
adversary goes through a query phase
where it can make queries that are of
one of two types it can make Cipher text
queries and token queries so in a cipher
text query it's going to Output a plain
text XI and get back an encryption of XI
in a token query it'll output a
predicate fi and get back a token for fi
so it can um run several of these
queries and issue them
adaptively and then when the query when
the adversary wants to be challenged
it'll output two um predicates fstar Z
and fstar one that it thinks it can
distinguish between and this is subject
to the Restriction that these two
predicates have to um have the same
value on all of the pl texts that were
queried so
far now the Challenger is going to flip
over random bit B and give back a token
for f star of
B and the adversary can ask some more
queries subject to the same restriction
as before and finally the adversary
outputs a guess B Prime of this bit B
and it wins if B Prime equals B and um
we say that our scheme has predicate
privacy if no polinomial time adversary
can win this game with more than
negligible
probability so here I've shown the game
um in terms of a token challenge where
in the challenge phase the adversary is
outputting these um two predicates F0
and F1 and this corresponds to the
predicate privacy game if we replace the
challenge step with um a cipher text
challenge where the adversary is giving
two plain texts and getting back an
encryption of one of them then this
corresponds to the plain text privacy
notion which um is already achieved by
these public key predicate encryption
schemes okay so in in our work we um
construct a predicate encryption scheme
with predicate privacy and we do this by
transforming the inner product scheme of
cats sah high and Waters into a
symmetric key scheme that has not only
plain Tex privacy but also predicate
privacy
so um so here's what the scheme looks
like um the functionality is that we
have a plain text X which is a vector X1
through XM and predicates corresponding
to vectors V1 through VM and a predicate
for a vector v evaluates to true on X if
the inner product of X and V is equal to
zero mod
n so the key intuition for how we
construct our scheme is that for inner
products the cipher text and the tokens
actually play symmetric roles in the
functionality and the security game so
what I mean by this is well well you can
view the cipher text as an encryption of
the plain text and you can view the
token as an encryption of the predicate
and now in the inner product
functionality these two vectors are
treated symmetrically and same thing in
the security game so if we can come up
with a scheme where um the cipher text
is Created from the plain text in
exactly the same way that the the token
is Created from the predicate then if we
prove plain text privacy this
automatically implies predicate
privacy
so our initial scheme looks a lot like
the scheme of ksw which means that in a
relatively straightforward way we can
prove plain Tex privacy um and the next
step is that we show through a series of
modifications that our scheme is
actually indistinguishable from one
where the cipher texts and the tokens
are treated symmetrically and so the
plain text privacy that we already
proved gives us predicate privacy for
free Okay so before I go into the scheme
you might ask um why we're even
considering inner products and it's it
turns out that inner product query is
actually allow us to make um a lot of
other more expressive queries as well so
I'll just give um a simple example of
this
um so suppose we have an inner product
scheme that has these four algorithms
setup encrypt generate token and query
that gives us the inner product
functionality um I'm just going to show
how we can use this to actually get
equality testing on elements of ZN so if
um if our plain texts are elements of ZN
and our predicates are equality testing
um we can use an in product scheme of
Dimension 2 so to
encrypt an element J of
ZN we first create a vector which is
minus J and 1 and we encrypt this vector
using our inner product scheme and to
generate a token for testing equality to
an element K that's in ZN then we first
create a vector which is 1 comma K and
use the inner product scheme to generate
a token for that so now the query
algorithm works exactly as before we
just run the inner product query
algorithm and you can see that the inner
product of these two vectors minus J and
1 and 1 and K is equal to zero um if and
only if J is equal de K yeah this is
equality mod end right yes this is mod
is a very special end that you generate
as part of your uh
scheme it is mod n which is the the N
which is part of our scheme
right okay so that's just a simple
example but you can also show that inner
using inner products you can come up
with predicate encryption schemes to do
polinomial evaluation and using those
you can do conjunctions and um
disjunctions and exact thresholds and
other
things okay so I'll just show um sort of
at a high level what our scheme looks
like in our scheme we use bilinear maps
so we have uh two groups G and GT which
are finite cyclic groups of order n
where here n is um a composite which is
the product of four primes P Q R and S
and we can write G as the product of
these four subgroups GP GQ G and
GS and we have a bilinear map e which
takes G cross G to GT the bilinear
property says that if we pair G to the A
and G to the B it's equal to the pairing
of g g to the ab so we can pull the
exponents out and um the map has to be
non- degenerate which says that um if G
generates the entire group G then the
pairing of G with itself generates the
entire Target
group okay so there are a couple useful
mathematical properties that we need in
our scheme um so one is that if we pair
a with the product of B and C we can
split this up into the pairing of a with
b and the product of A and C um the
other useful property which comes up in
groups of composite order is that when
we pair two elements G and H which are
of relatively prime order
um basically they cancel out and the
result is one so um this this means when
g& H come from distinct sub subgroups
for example if G is from the subgroup of
order P and H is from the subgroup of
order Q when we pair them together it's
just going to cancel out and we get
one that you mention yeah basically um
you can write each element as a
generator of the group to some power so
if you look at um an element of the
subgroup of order P you can write it as
um G to the QRS to some power and if you
do that for both of the elements then
you can pull out the powers and you have
a pqrs all in the exponent um so it's
going to equal
one okay so again we have a plain text X
which is Vector X1 through XM and a
predicate V1 through
VM and
uh we want the evaluation of a a token
on a cipher text to come out to one if
the inner product is equal to zero so as
a first attempt um we can say for the
cipher text first just generate a random
element G of the subgroup GQ and raise G
to the powers X1 through XM and for the
token similarly choose a random value H
um in GQ and raise H to the V1 through
VM so now we can easily see if we just
pair these elements together um
component by component and multiply all
the
pairings uh we end up with the we end up
with e of G comma H with the inner
product of X and V mod n and the
exponent so if the inner product is
equal to zero then this value is going
to be equal to 1 in the Target
group so this gives us the functionality
we want but there's um a lot of problems
with it so one problem is that we get
Cipher text Cipher text interaction what
I mean by that is if you look at the
cipher text which is g to the X1 through
G to the XM we can learn a lot about the
XIs just by doing pairings on these um
these terms so for example um you can
learn whether the inner product of X1 X3
and X2 X4 is equal to zero by pairing
the components in this way and similarly
for the
tokens so the solution to this is that
we multiply in masking factors um so in
the cipher text we can multiply in uh
random values from the subgroup
gr and for the tokens we can multiply in
GS so now um because of the cancellation
property that I mentioned for if we pair
a cipher text component with a token
component the r and the S are going to
cancel out be from because they're from
distinct subgroups um but if we
improperly combine two Cipher text
components or two token components then
the randomization is from the same group
and it's not going to cancel out and the
result will look
random okay so another problem that we
still have is that um we can sort of do
partial evaluation and what I mean by
that is um you could basically combine
just a subset of the components and
learn something about the inner product
of um only some of the components so for
example you could learn the result of um
learn whether the inner product of X1 X2
and V1 V2 is equal to zero by doing this
pairing so the solution to that is um in
the exponent of the GP subgroup we
encode an equation which evaluates to
zero if all of the components are
combined and in the right order so
roughly what we do is um in the cipher
text we multiply in these terms F to the
C1 through F to the CM and in the token
we multiply in F to the D1 and through F
to the DM and these C1 CIS and D are
random but subject to the constraint
that the inner product of the vector C
and the vector D is equal to zero so now
only if you combine all of the
components and in the right order will
they cancel out and you get something
that does not look
random sorry C fixed in part of the
secret
key that's just something
that's
um yeah it's part of the secret key
um so
see so I mean what we do is actually not
exactly this um but it's something
similar which is also an equation which
comes out to zero if you um pair things
correctly so part of it is from the
secret key and part of it is Randomness
that you generate um in these
algorithms okay so to summarize we have
these four subgroups which um each play
different roles in the GQ subgroup we
encode the plain text and the predicate
and the exponent and do the in product
computation um we use the gr subgroup to
mask the cipher text components the GS
subgroup um similarly masks the token
components and the GP subgroup is used
to ensure that all the components are
used and in the right
order um so in conclusion we achieved a
predicate encryption scheme that has
predicate privacy in the symmetric key
setting and supports in product queries
and
from in product queries we can also
achieve equality testing polinomial
evaluation and conjunctive and
disjunctive formulas and what this means
is that um in encrypted file storage
scenarios on the cloud uh a user can
give the server a token to retrieve
encrypted files satisfying a particular
predicate P without revealing what that
predicate is so that's the end of my
talk and I'll take any questions you
have a realistic example where predicate
privacy um so I mean to me in the file
storage case um that's a case where it
would be important because you're
storing your files encrypted and now you
want to retrieve the one satisfying a
particular predicate and you don't
necessarily want to reveal to the server
what you're searching
on maybe I don't understand the
definition of predate if I take a
conjunction query A and B predicate
privacy just say you you took a
conjunction of two two elements it
doesn't say what A and B it's not even
going to reveal that you took a
conjunction of equality I mean what you
define as predicate privacy the fact
that it is a conjunction of something
right uh or do you you won't even know
that it's a conjunction of two things I
know but but that's what you you try to
achieve by predicate privacy the fact
that it is a conjunction
right not
m um so I'm not sure I understand the
question okay
sure I don't have the numbers top of my
head if you take a let's say 1024 RS RSA
sized modulus and chop it into four
equally sized parts are they safe
against elliptic curve attacks are they
safe
against usually RS say you have Nal PQ
now you have Nal pqrs right so it means
that we need something much larger
size much
what's the current limit on elliptic
curves elliptic
curve Factory go clearly your your Neer
is that that's much smaller that much
smaller okay 50 digits so I'm sorry
that's about 50 digits
okay so any more
questions so actually I'm just curious
about this public key definition yeah I
can see the issue but you still can
define it I mean so what I'm saying is
maybe the it seems like if you can do it
it will imply program infuscation right
isn't it true that's something that um
people have mentioned so it's possible
that you could Define it in some other
way not with the same kind of
indistinguishability game but maybe you
could um have a sort of simulation based
definition where you want to say that
um an
adversary basically um that the the
cipher text and tokens give the
adversary no more information than he
would get by just having access to a
um but that's exactly so what I'm saying
is if you have this you know talking to
the function f one way to achieve
programation is you encrypt X and then
you know translate and get F ofx so in
particular it does give you an ability
to evalate F ofx right for any input you
want so you know if you can say that the
best you can do for any attack or
whatever you can learn from this you can
get from from giving Oracle access to F
that would be exactly the programation
definition yeah so at least for some
crazy functions of f it's not possible
but maybe for equality queries it's kind
of funny so this direction goes other
the way around this thing is stronger
than programation right yeah so but
maybe for the classes I'm just curious
like for Point functions can you take
like PR skaters for Point function and
turn them into this uh predicate
encryptions uh that's Anonymous I right
oh I see so this
equality function you hide the secret
that's already
possible wait a second but then
Anonymous I there is a direction other
way around like anous I would I mean it
doesn't give as far as I know Anonymous
I doesn't give you appliation of Point
functions the
expl foration you wanted that key so you
want need but could be
foration confused
here I'm just curious so it wasn't
explored by a guest know some people in
this room this
connection yes so we didn't explore it
but I think worth exploring the
connection any other
questions okay good let's stack the
speaker
so uh the next speaker is uh our own uh
s Kamara and he'll tell you about
structure encryption and control to
disclosure thanks uh so yeah everybody
can hear me yeah okay so as we know said
I'll be speaking about structured
encryption and control disclosure and
this is Joint work with Melissa
Chase so the setting that we consider
here is out of cloud storage which we've
heard a lot about today so here we have
a cloud provider that offers storage as
a service and we have clients that want
to pay the Scout provider to store um
their data right so they just send it
over and um as we all know there's a lot
of services based on cloud um on um
cloud storage so there is web based
email like Gmail or Hotmail illa weave
live mesh Windows Azure has Azure
storage and Amazon has S3 and there are
um a lot more services uh Beyond
these okay so cloud storage is great
there's a lot of advantages but really
the main disadvantage is security right
and the main concern here is basically
what's going to happen to my data right
and typically this is addressed by Cloud
providers uh in the following way they
say well don't worry too much about it
we're going to encrypt the data we're
going to authenticate it it'll be backed
up we have access control our data
centers are very secure we have guards
we have biometric um access control so
nobody's going to be able to get to your
data and these are all great um these
are all great measures but they really
only provide you security against either
Outsiders so like hackers for example um
or other tenants so other clients that
are using the same cloud storage
infrastructure so really uh the type of
a model that we consider here and that
you've heard about in previous talks
today um is basically one where we we
don't trust a cloud operator himself
right so the question is instead of
providing security against Outsiders and
other tenants can can we provide
security against the cloud operator
himself okay so I might say why do we
want to protect against the cloud these
Cloud providers are rational entities
right they they're trying to run a
business they have a reputation uh it's
not in their interest to sort of do all
these malicious things uh so you might
want security against the cloud for
multiple reasons one of them is just
plain lack of trust if you're for
example a pharmaceutical company that's
investing you know billions or in R&D
you're probably not going to trust a
cloud provider to store your data or you
could be a government agency who
basically won't trust anybody to store
any of its data um and there's also
legal um legal uh situations where if
you're a hospital or publicly traded
company by law you might not be able to
disclose some of your data to a third
party okay
so in this work what we're concerned
about is confidentiality right so I have
data I want to store it in the cloud uh
but I don't want the cloud operator to
see my data so there's very simple
solutions to this problem one of them is
to just use encryption so we take our
data we encrypt it we send it over to
the cloud and whenever we want to
perform some operation on this data we
send a message and the cloud Returns the
encrypted data back we decrypt it and
then perform our operations locally
right and obviously the downside to this
approach is that there's large
communication complexity right it
doesn't really scale well if if we're
talking about terabytes of data we don't
really want to be sending this around um
each time we want to do some some
operation so another solution is to take
the data when when we have it in our
possession and to build an index right
so if I have my email collection for
example I can build a Keyword Index
which allows me to do keyword search
over this data then I can store the
index locally encrypt all my emails send
it to the cloud and whenever I want to
retrieve some emails I just send uh
sorry I query my I query my index and I
figure out which which emails contain
the keyword and then I ask the cloud to
return those specific encrypted emails
okay and this has good communication
complexity but the downside is that it
requires large uh storage locally right
so the size of this index is going to
grow as a function of uh as a function
of my email
archive okay so the question is can we
achieve The Best of Both Worlds can we
have um constant storage at the client
and small communication
complexity and this is essentially the
problem of uh searching un encrypted
data which was uh first considered by S
Wagner Imp perig in 2001 and basically
what we want is we want a system uh that
the client can use to encrypt its data
and whenever it wants to work on a
subset of these documents it can send a
token that encodes a particular keyword
the cloud can then take this token which
hides the information about the keyword
combine it with the encrypted uh data
and return uh the specific documents
that contain the keyword okay
all right uh so this problem of
searchable encryption can be addressed
using general tools so one of them is
two- party computation um but here uh if
you use to party computation the number
of rounds that you're going to have to
use is going to be linear in the size of
the data um and on top of that the
server is going to have to do work
that's polinomial in the size of the
data so this really doesn't give you any
advantage over just sending the data
back and
forth so you could also use techniques
from uh gooski um which were called
oblivious Rams but here sort of the
overhead is going to be fairly large for
every read and write of your RAM so you
have a program that does keyword search
for every read and write that this
program does you're going to require
logarithmic number of rounds and py log
um work on the
server another thing you could use as
Craig mentioned this morning is fully
home oric encryption and here you can
get a one round solution uh but the
server computation is going to be
polinomial and the size of the data and
again this is sort of large for the
types of parameters that uh that we have
in mind
so people have tried to solve the
problem um by designing crypto systems
or schemes specifically for searchable
encryption uh so there's been a lot of
work in the symmetric key setting in the
public key setting and basically most of
the schemes um have a one round solution
but the work at the server is linear in
the number of of data items so if n is
your number of emails uh then the the
server the the computation have for the
server is linear net um but in 2006 uh
work that we did with
G Andi we gave a solution that had one
round and that had sublinear search time
for the server and in particular it's
optimal it's basically uh linear in the
number of documents that contain the
keyword okay so so triple encryption is
is is great the schemes are fairly
efficient um and they basically allows
you to do private keyword search over
encrypted data right over encrypted text
Data sorry sure uh if you can do the
last thing then it reveals some
information about the keyword
right in particular information about
the number
of yeah so so the schemes they really at
least all the symmetric key schemes
including including this one uh they do
leak some information about about the
keywords it's it's sort of
they the the leak information about your
access pattern basically so it's not
specifically about the keyword but
there's a little bit of the statistical
information and you could you know sort
of uh you know keep monitoring sort of
the access pattern and eventually guess
something so yeah but how I mean without
getting into details how the definitions
take care I mean how to make definitions
kind of say yeah so it's actually kind
of tricky right because you have to
weaken the definitions uh to basically
leak a little bit of information right
so if you're defining things you know
using the general tools it's it's fairly
easy you have an ideal functionality and
you can just but here you actually have
to weaken it to to allow say it can be
done it's just not obvious you guys do
it
but also unencrypted system working time
logarithmic in the number of docents
that's what they consider efficient no
you can do it you can do it sort of with
optimally with uh basically the server
computation time is output sensitive so
it's just all those documents there you
have to go over all document exactly
which which is linear in number of
documents documents with the word it's
linear in the number of documents with
the keyword the number of so you just
use a reverse index just use a reverse
index on your data and you get optimal
optimal search time in the UN encrypted
case in the encrypted case you have to
use a index but apply the crypto to it
in order to make it uh to make it
secure okay so yes okay so searchable
encryption is great we can search for
encrypted data um but really it's sort
of it's actually fairly Limited in terms
of functionality right so we can do
keyword searches over text data but a
lot of the data that's generated isn't
Text data right um and in particular a
lot of this data that's not text data we
don't really care about doing keyword
searches over right um so the question
is can we privately query other types of
encrypted data and in particular things
like Maps or image collections social
networks or web page archives right so
this is a problem that we consider in
this paper and um so we focus on a
particular type of data which is a graph
structured data and really this type of
data is ubiquitous and is being
generated at um at a huge rate right so
basically any communication between you
know between people generates graphs
right so if you look at email headers if
you look at phone logs uh you're going
to get huge graphs if you look at
research papers and citations and
bibliographies you also get big graphs
um a lot of sort of network topology um
things generate these huge graphs you
know as level graphs or Internet scale
graphs um as well of course social
networks right are generating huge huge
amounts of graph data um and web
Crawlers for search engines right for
Bing or Google they're generating
massive massive graph
um and finally you can also think of
maps as graphs where you have basically
intersections are uh the nodes of your
graph and the roads between the
intersections are your edges so we felt
that this was sort of an interesting
type of data and we wanted to see if we
could encrypt it in a way that we could
actually do graph queries on top of this
data okay so the results are basically
so okay so we introduced this idea of
structured encryption which is basically
a generalization of searchable
encryption to other types of data not
just text data but arbitrarily
structured data uh we have a formal
security definition which is simulation
based and we give a few constructions so
we show how to do adjacency queries on
en cryptog graphs which are basically
given two nodes do they have an edge uh
we try to do neighbor queries on en
cryptog graphs so given a node uh I want
to get back all the nodes that have that
are adjacent to that um to that node and
we also do uh something called Focus
subgraph queries on encrypted web graphs
and these are sort of more complex types
of queries and I'll explain those later
um okay and finally we consider uh sort
of a new application of structured
encryption um and therefore searchable
encryption to a problem that we refer to
as control disclosure um and we show
some applications of or we sort of
mentioned some applications of control
disclosure to cloud-based data brokering
which if I have some time I'll explain
uh what that
is
okay so for stred encryption so if you
take the example of of graph structure
data right so the idea is we have our
client he has uh this this graph
he wants to encrypt it send it to the
cloud and later he wants to make some
query some graph query on this graph so
he's going to send a token which is
going to encode the the graph query he
wants to make but it's going to hide the
information about the query he's making
and then the cloud is going to be able
to return the encrypted uh the
encryptions of whatever the answer is
okay so for this particular type of
encryption scheme right you can see sort
of the message space is a little bit
weird right so typically for typical
encryption schemes the message space is
either a bit string or some element of a
group right but now we're encrypting
something that has a lot more that's a
lot more
structure so the first thing that we
have to do is we have to understand what
exactly is our message space so the way
we describe the message space is is as
follows so we say if so we okay so we
view the input as some structur data and
then we say we're going to decompose
this structure data into two elements
one of them is the data structure that
encodes the structure of the data and
the other one are the data items which
basically are just bit strings right
which sort of have whatever information
we want to iate with uh with
um with the structure encoded by the
data structure so as an example if you
have an email archive right so these are
just emails then we're going to view it
as a combination of a um of a Keyword
Index and then the text in the emails
okay so this index just encodes the
keywords associated with each of the
each of the emails and if I query if I
query this data structure if I query
this index on a keyword I'm going to get
pointers into the particular emails that
contain the keyword
okay so another example is uh for social
networks so here we have a social
network and we're going to view this as
a combination of a graph which encodes
the friendships between uh between the
people and their profiles for example
okay and if I do a graph query on this
on this graph I'm going to get pointers
to the different to the different
profiles
okay
okay so SE encryption scheme is composed
of five algorithms uh the first one is
the key generation algorithm that Tak a
security parameter appos the symmetric
key uh then there's an encryption
algorithm that takes the key takes the
data structure Delta which encodes the
structure and then a vector which
consist of the data items okay and it
outputs an encrypted data structure
gamma and a cipher Tex C and this is
what the client is going to run on his
structured data in order to generate um
The Cypher text which is composed of of
the actual encrypted data items and the
encrypted data structure and that's what
he's going to send to the
cloud uh whenever the client wants to
make a query on this data he's going to
use the token algorithm on his query
which is going to generate a token which
is going to send to the cloud and the
cloud is going to take the token and the
encrypted data structure run this query
algorithm on the encrypted data
structure with a token and this is going
to Output a set of pointers right I is
just a set of numbers which basically
point to the particular data items that
satisfy the query and then it can just
go fetch those encrypted items and send
them back and then the client can just
decri those item those items
individually
okay so as far as security uh so we give
a definition which we refer to as uh
security against adaptive chosen query
attack so it's simulation based and
essentially the guarantee is that given
The Cypher Tex no adversary can learn
any information about the data or the
queries other than what can be learned
from the access and the search patterns
and this is even if the queries are made
adaptively so by adaptive by by adaptive
queries I mean even if the makes as
queries as a function of the answers of
previous queries or as a function of the
cipher text okay and so there's this
caveat in the definition which says that
um nothing can be learned other than
what can be deduced from the access and
the search patterns and which basically
means that the schemes leak the access
and the search pattern and to be more
precise what I mean by access and search
pattern is the following so the access
patterns are basically the pointers to
the encrypted documents that satisfy the
query right which we're willing to leak
in this case because we want an
efficient solution and in any case the
Ser we want the server to return these
encrypted data items so we might as well
just leak it so there are techniques to
hide this but they're much more
expensive um and we search and and we
and we leak we leak something else which
is the query pattern which is basically
where their query is repeated
okay um okay and this is pretty standard
at least in the case of symetric
searchable encryption all the schemes
leak leak these things um some leak more
but this is sort of of the best we can
do without interaction um at least so
far so so we have the simulation based
definition and this definition implies
lower bound on the size of the tokens
right in particular so the lower bound
is uh Lambda time log n where Lambda is
the number of data items that satisfy
the query and N is the number of data
items okay and this lower bound is in
the standard model so in the anoral
model you can do
better how do I mean is it Pro is it
obvious I don't see L it's it's sort of
obvious I mean it's the thing is that
this so This definition is adaptive
basically so you get into a situation
where the simulator basically has to
sort of commit to some encryption and
then he's going to get queries after
he's committed to to the cipher text and
he has to answer those queries correctly
right so he's have to generate tokens
that are actually going to work um but
he only gets the query so he only gets
information on the query after after
words um and if you want to be able to
satisfy any possible query basically
your token is going to you're going to
have to have enough tokens sort of in
your token space to satisfy any possible
answer so so in terms of the size it's
going to be basically related to the
size of all the different answers that
that you have to be able to sort of
simulate um and the login is really just
because what you what you encode in
terms of the responses are Pointers into
the items and you have n items so you
need log in in order to so that's pretty
much it um consider non simulation based
what did you consider nonsimulation
based definitions or is there something
simulation based security not in this
work just consider the simulation Bas
definition which um you know which has
some nice properties right typically you
typically prefer these types of
definitions they compose easier um you
know they're sort of more natural also
so
um but yeah you could also formulate a
you know an indistinguishability based
definition
okay so we consider so as I mentioned we
consider we give uh different
constructions uh so we do adjacency
queries on encrypted graphs and we do
this uh so we design a scheme that
handles lookup queries on en crypted
matrices and then we basically just look
at the The adjacency Matrix
representation on the graph and then
just use the scheme on top of it uh we
also do neighbor queries on encrypted
graphs and we actually show that this
can be built from any any uh structured
encryption scheme that handles keyword
searches so basically any symmetric
searchable encryption scheme um we and
then as I mentioned we we do also Focus
subgraph queries on encrypted web graphs
and for this we need um a scheme that
handles keyword searches on encrypted
data so basically an SSE scheme and a
scheme that handles neighbor queries on
cryptog
graphs so I'll talk a little bit about
how we do neighbor queries on en cryptog
graphs um and then I'll talk about how
we do Focus sub graph
queries depending on how much time I
have
so okay so how do we do neighbor queries
on cryptog graphs so basically what we
want is we have this uh the structur
data which looks um looks as follows so
we have this graph and then we have the
data items and basically the yellow data
item is basically whatever data we want
to associate with the yellow node right
um Etc so this is our this is our input
we want to encrypt this send into the
cloud and then generate a token um to do
enigh query so we send a token for the
green node and then the cloud is able to
figure out which encrypted documents um
are connected to the green
node okay so the building blocks we use
we use a dictionary which is basically
just a key Value Store uh we use a su
random function and we use some form of
non-committing symmetric encryption and
this we can build simply using a sud
random function and exor in this case we
have a lower bound on the token size um
or we can use random oron X or and we
don't have to worry about the the lower
bound we get tokens that are as large as
the security
parameter sure uh is the dynamically
changing or no so this is everything
here is
static um okay so what does the scheme
look like so this is our
graph uh the first thing we do is we
generate the the adjacency list
representation of this graph which
consists of for every node we just write
down all um all the nodes that are
adjacent into it so uh there should be a
familiar familiar data structure uh and
then what we do is we use the suit
random function on on the nodes right so
we just uh turn them into random looking
values and then we use the
non-committing encryption scheme um on
the list of edges right for each
node um and the key is a function of the
particular node that that that we're
working with okay and then we just store
this in our dictionary
and that's what we call an
encrypted data structure and we send
this along with the encrypted documents
uh to the cloud and whenever we want to
whenever we want to do a neighor query
in a particular node we send a token
that has this form so the first element
is just the evaluation of this random
function on the particular node that
we're trying to query and then we
generate this key for the non-committing
encryption scheme uh we send both of
these elements to the server the server
takes the encrypted data structure so
this dictionary um queries it using the
first element which is this random
looking string uh the dictionary Returns
the associated value which is basically
the non-committed encryption of um of uh
the nodes that are adjacent to it and
then it uses the key to decrypt and get
back which nodes are connected to it
right so it's fairly simple um that's
essentially how the scheme works you
have to take care of some details but
this is at a high level how it
works um okay so that was neighbor
queries on encrypted graphs
uh now so okay
so you learn a lot of GRA structure this
way right because the guy actually know
some is connected to like five
no so this is information yeah yeah so
so you do and sort of in this you don't
learn record because
record so in this area right it's sort
of we're trying to get this trying to
get the right trade-off between
efficiency and security right and we
know how to do these things like
completely securely we use oblivious and
and and and we're done but you know here
we're really trying to get something
that's actually practical so we are
leaking some information and to be
honest it's not clear like we don't have
a good way of of assessing how much
information you know how dangerous this
is right but we're sort of willing to
say you know we're going to leak this
much information in order to get
efficiency and hopefully that's
hopefully it's not too much but you feel
it's much better than just saying This
Is My Graph I mean in the open but the
records all
encrypted uh so this is course course to
realize the problem but you're saying
the kind of information especially from
a large gr that you learn by just saying
there is some random note connected to
this Five Guys
connect will be a lot L information and
it would take a long time before you
could actually reconstruct any
meaningful information but you know but
we don't have a good way of assessing
that right it's sort of but in but sort
of from a practical point of view it's
better what we have now which is nothing
right it's definition right so you know
exactly what information
is no but what I mean is is the
following so so we know so we know what
is being leaked by the scheme so so we
we can we can characterize what is being
leaked in some way we can say it's the
access pattern it's this these pointers
and these elements right now the problem
is that when you're actually using this
multiple times then it's not clear like
if so if I look at the information
that's being leaked over multiple
multiple what queries right I can start
to sort of make inferences about so I I
can start I can try to guess what you
might be searching for so so okay so
take take the case of keyword search
right so if I see that you know you're
doing a bunch of searches that hit a lot
of documents right and I know that you
work at at a particular company maybe I
can start infering thing about refirming
things about what you're searching for
and the more of this data I get the
better you know I can infer so it's not
I mean so it's in that sense that we
don't know exactly how
to statistically what what we'll be you
know what what we're leaking
so and and you don't want to use say p
along with public encryption or
something because it's in yeah I mean
you could use you know these sort of
generic techniques I mean you could use
fully homeor encryption you could use
oblivious Rams but you know but even
this something like this is yeah yeah
pure I mean is not really
yeah
okay so so the example I gave which was
neighbor queries on graphs is really
sort of a simple type of query on a
graph right um but in a lot of cases we
have more complicated types of graphs we
have sort of objects that have um that
might mix different types of structure
right so one example are web graphs
which are basically just collections of
web pages right and web pages of
hyperlinks so web graphs essentially
consists of Text data which is in the
pages and of graph data right which is
which are the hyperlinks between the
pages so you can do simple queries on
web graphs you could ask for all the
pages that are linked you know to from a
particular page or all the pages that
link to a particular page so these would
just be plain neighbor queries on a web
graph but you could also ask more
complicated queries on web graphs right
because they have this extra structure
so you could ask queries that basically
mix both text the text and the graph
structure of the data right and one
example um so and where this comes up a
lot for examp for web graphs are for uh
search engine algorithms right u in
particular so the more modern search
engine algorithms like page rank or hits
basically they don't when they when you
when you do a keyword search um in your
search engine and they give you back a
ranking they don't just look at the text
data right of the web pages they look at
the text but they also sort of do some
computation on the link structure so
they mix
both um and so yes some of the more
well-known algorithms are are page rank
obviously um that Google uses but in
particular I highlight Cleber hits
algorithm because this uses actually
Focus subgraph queries which is what
what we do and there's some derivatives
of this algorithm salsa and a bunch of
others okay so what is a focus subgraph
query so the way the search engine
algorithms work is basically the first
thing they do so they look at the web
graph they compute a focus subgraph and
then they run this iterative algorithm
on this focus subgraph and uh then they
output a ranking okay and then they send
back you know the 100 best uh best best
pages so if I'm doing a keyword search
for crypto then a focus subgraph is
essentially the following so first I do
a keyword search over all the web pages
and I figure out which Pages contain the
word crypto so in this case it's these
three pages and then I add to the
subgraph any page that's connected to
these Pages or any pages that connects
to those pages right so I just add all
these pages and that's my focus subgraph
okay so that's all that
means okay so how can we how can we
encrypt a graph or web Gra so that we
can do Focus subgraph queries on it so
one approach is to just take this web
graph and encrypt it with um a
structured encryption scheme that
handles keyword searches output a cipher
text and then encrypt it with a
structure encryption scheme that handles
neighbor queries and output a you know a
second cipher text and the CER text is
the combination of of both right and
this approach won't work because if I
give you a token for for the keyword
search for example you'll be able to
figure out or the server will be to
figure out which documents or which web
pages contain the keyword uh but then I
still need to give you a token so that
you can get the neighbor the neighbors
of that particular web page right and I
don't know I can't predict what the
answer to that query is going to be so
there's no way of me of there's no way
for me to do this interact uh without
interaction okay so in the paper we sort
of introduced this chaining technique
which allows us to combine structured
encryption schemes um in order to
combine in order to generate a
structured encryption scheme that's more
complex and to handle Focus subgraph
queries we combine sear encryption for
keyword search with seu encryption for
uh neighbor queries
and the nice thing about this approach
is that it preserves the token size of
the first scheme okay so the token sizes
don't add up it's not like you have to
send one for each struction encryption
scheme that you use you just send one
token for the first
one okay uh so this training technique
is uh is useful but it requires an extra
property from the structured encryption
scheme which we call um associativity
and essentially what this means is that
uh you have a more complicated message
space which includes so the data
structure Delta the items uh the data
items and also um a vector of what we
call semi-private information which is
information that's private in one way
but public in another so and I'll
explain a little bit what that means um
and the sort of the answer space is also
a little bit more complicated you get
pointers to the data items but you also
get this uh the semi-private information
okay and it turns out so there is a
scheme um that is that handles keyword
uh keyword searches that is associative
uh but it's not secure in this adaptive
sense which is which is what we need so
in the paper we uh we propos a scheme
that's does the handle skiw searches
that's associative and that's adaptably
secure okay so uh a little bit more
precisions on what I mean by
associativity so these are the
algorithms that we had initially for
structured encryption so now a scheme is
a structured encryption scheme is
associative if uh if it has the
following property so on top of the data
structure and the data items we also
have the the semi the semi-private
information
um and what this means that basically
for each data item I can associate
another item right so for M1 I have V1
for M2 I have V2 okay and what's the
point of doing this the point is that
when I run my query algorithm on the
encrypted data structure and the token
I'm not only going to get the pointers
into the data items that are relevant
for this particular query but I'm also
going to get the associated data and I'm
going to get this in clear text right so
it's not
encrypted okay so it might seem a little
bit weird why do I want to release
information but it turns out that we we
actually need this in order to handle
complex queries okay so I don't know how
much time I have left
but
um all right so how do we do Focus
subgraph queries on web graph so um okay
so actually before yeah let me go over
first okay so we view a f so we view a
web graph as a combination of three
things there's a Keyword Index um a
graph and and then the data items okay
so now our message space uh looks like
this we want to encrypt it send tokens
and then get back the encryptions of the
documents associated with the focus
subgraph so we're going to build our
encryption scheme for Focus subgraph
queries um out of two other schemes one
that handles keyword searches and one
that handles neighbor queries so given
this web graph right so a bunch of web
pages with with
hyperlinks uh the first thing we do is
we use
the structured encryption scheme for
neighbor queries and we generate tokens
for neighbor queries for each um for
each node of this web graph so we start
with the first page we generate a token
for neighbor queries then we go to the
second one we generate a token for
neighbor queries
Etc
okay then we use the structured
encryption scheme to handle keyword
searches um and we encrypt the following
things so as the data items we use the
web pages right so just the plain Text
data and as the associated semi-private
information for each web page we encrypt
the token right the token that handles
neighbor queries and so we do this for
all the web
pages and so this is going to generate a
cipher text
right um okay so then we use our
structured encryption scheme for
neighbor queries and we use that to
encrypt the graph structure of this web
graph so we just read this as a graph
and we just encrypt this using the uh
the encryption scheme for neighbor CS so
this going to generate so now we have
two Cypher text one the handle keyword
search is the one that handles ques and
our Cipher text for focus subgraphs is
basically just uh the combination of the
two okay so how do we actually perform
the queries on the cipher text so this
is what the cipher text looks like um
our token is basically just a token for
keyword search right so we want a query
for the word crypto we generate a token
for crypto using the stru encryption
scheme to handle keyword search we send
this to the cloud and then the server
uses that in conjunction with this uh
encryption scheme right that handles
keyword searches and this with this
token so the Cy text with this token is
going to allow the server to figure out
which uh which encrypto documents
contain the keyword crypto right and
because of this associativity property
it'll also um enable it to figure out
the tokens associated with those pages
okay so that's why we actually want to
release this information in um in clear
text so we just so okay so in this case
there's just one uh one file that
contains word crypto so we get a pointer
to that file and we get this token um
and then we use this
token together with uh the encryption
scheme that handles neighbor queries
right so now we have the encryption of
the graph structure we use this token
here with this and this is this is going
to allow us to figure out which no
um are neighbors of the yellow
node basically just one and three okay
so in this way we've done Focus subgraph
queries which are basically more complex
than normal graph queries right uh by
combining these two different types of
encryption schemes without using
interaction okay so if I have a little
bit more time I'll talk about control
disclosure or okay um okay so the
typical application for structured
encryption or or searchable encryption
is doing private queries on encrypted
data right this is sort of what what
we're all familiar with um but and this
is this is fine uh but there may be
situations where you actually want the
cloud or the server to do some
computations on your data and maybe you
don't you
know you don't care that much that it
learns some information about your data
right so I have this social network I
send it off to the cloud and I want the
cloud to compute some very complicated
function of this graph and and my data
is so huge huge that there's just no way
I'm going to be able to use fully home
warer encryption or two- party
computation it's just not feasible so
maybe I don't mind it learning you know
parts of my graph right um okay so that
could happen now what if the algorithm
is a local algorithm right so the
algorithm doesn't actually need to see
all of the data right it only needs to
see part of the data right so again I
have this social network I wanted to
compute something about my network um
but really it only needs to see like a
small subset of My Graph right so in
that case maybe I don't want it to see
the rest of my graph right maybe part of
my social network is related to my
family so I don't really want him to
like go snoop snoop around there but I
want them to compute something over the
part of my social network that's related
to my work okay so I don't mind them
learning information that's related to
my to my work friends but I don't want
them to learn anything about my
family um so if the algorithm is local
right this type of security guarantee
could make
sense um and so control disclosure is
basically just sort of me mechanism that
would allow you to disclose pieces of
your data right so you encrypt your data
you send it off you want the server or
the cloud to perform some computation on
your data you don't mind him learning
parts of the data but you don't want him
to learn all of the data right so you
want to be able to just disclose um a
subset of um of the
data okay so here again if you have the
social network you want to encrypt it
send it and then I'm going to send the
cloud a token this token is going to
allow the cloud to recover basically a
subgraph in this case right just a small
subgraph and then it can evaluate some
function f on the subgraph and send me
back the answer
okay um okay and so you can use
structured encryption to do this uh to
to do this kind of
thing um and so you know this could be
useful just sort of independently in of
itself but one application or another
application is to sort of these
cloud-based data brokerage systems so um
if you haven't heard of these so there's
a few examples that I know of one of
them is uh is being developed at
Microsoft it's called Uh Dallas for now
uh there's another service called
infochimps
um and so the idea here is that you
might have some a producer of data like
the government for example that produces
massive amounts of data and it wants to
store it in the cloud right because
these are just really really massive
data sets and other people want to use
this data right so they want to want
they want to write applications that
that use this data um and so they're
going to interact with the cloud and
they're going to pay the cloud in order
to use the data right so they pay the
cloud a certain uh fee per query on this
data and then they get back just the
piece that they that they paid for and
then they do their computation and they
you know um and they're happy so so
that's what I'm calling a data brokerage
service um and this is actually being
built I mean like Microsoft has a
service that's available uh to to do
this so control disclosure could be used
um in the setting in the following way
so the client basically encrypts its
data sends it off um then so this is
sorry this is the producer of the data
and the consumer generates his query
sends it to the producer the owner of
the data the owner sends it back some
some token he sends us to the cloud the
cloud is able to recover a a sub piece
of the data whatever is actually needed
for the consumer to Performance
computation and then the consumer can
just you know run his app in the cloud
on this data okay and if you if you do
things this way as long as the producer
is willing to remain online and you know
um and send and send tokens around uh
the producer has a stronger guarantee
than what's available now in particular
he can actually get an accurate count of
which queries are made or how many
queries are made on his data um and this
is even if there's collusions between uh
the cloud and the and the
consumer
so okay that's pretty much it
so uh the next talk is uh is by jpia
from uh from Jones Hopkins and he'll
tell us about Cloud photography give
back control to the users
thanks so well uh I don't have to spend
much time on motivation since previous
uh talks
already um talked about
um why uh cryptography is important for
um the cloud definitely the cloud is a
big business opportunity and it will fly
only if um users will feel in control of
the data so I'm going to focus on two
cryptographic Primitives I've worked on
um uh that will enable um this but first
uh let
me
um thank my Coors um as I mentioned in
the previous talk here at Microsoft I'm
lucky because my first name starts with
a so I'm always mentioned in in all
these papers but uh
um so I will touch topics um related to
provable data possession which is with
the Rand Burns Red Z Mora harck gner
pson and Don song and I'll talk briefly
very briefly about some some new results
with uh dietro manini Jin sudik and uh
some work with seni Kamar Jonathan cats
that appeared in Asia Crypt and then I'm
going to talk about briefly about proxy
re encryption which is another
cryptographic tool and this is a join
work with Kevin Fu um Matt Green and
suzan hurger and some recent work uh
with Karen Benson and Susan enberg about
key privacy I'm not going to of course
uh touch focus on the details the idea
is that I'm going to mention some ideas
and if you want to know more we can talk
offline um so so the first part of the
talk is about approvable data possession
um and it's clear that cloud storage has
several uh benefits uh in particular
clients with limited resources can
Outsource their
storage um Cloud uh provides uh
universal access independent of location
for instance I can access my email I can
access my
documents um and it provides free
services like data B app recovery or
archival and one may argue that also for
the average user at list um cloud
storage provides more
security um because if someone even
though um these services are always
online and
available um they're usually monitored
uh by professional people so in case of
attack or in you know their intrusions
can be kind of easily detected in most
cases at least then for the average user
that you know usually doesn't choose uh
strong passwords or doesn't encrypt uh
file discs this may be a good
solution um in addition um what we focus
on here is mostly um archival storage so
uh there are legislations that require
uh data to be retained for several years
sometimes forever and the data has to be
available and and again adored data to
third party avoids the initial setup
cost and avoid this nightmares like
maintenance and
scalability so in particular we focus on
um um archives like the the the library
uh Congress in us they are supposed to
keep this data um available
forever and we are talking about several
hundreds of terabytes of data that has
to be kept uh forever
so so the question is for instance
suppose we want to provide um the
content of the library Congress
available to every uh taxpayer um the
idea is how can we make sure that this
information is actually stored correctly
as you might know you know the library
Congress contains books that people may
not even know the existence of so it
might be possible for a storage provider
to not necessarily delete but at least
uh put this information that is never
requested by users on a secondary
storage device like tapes okay so that
it's not deleted but it's not using
premium storage space okay so here we
are dealing with a sort of
adversary that is storing very large
amount of data okay and is willing to um
delete a percentage of this data not
necessarily again deletion means
destroying of data it means that this
data is moved to secondary storage
devices okay for
instance and unfortunately we cannot
trust uh third party um Cloud providers
necessarily um there's always um the
incentive to reduce cost and increase uh
profit and and so it might be that um
third party Cloud providers might
discard data that is not access or it's
rarely accessed and it could be that
there there is an incident and some data
is lost but since nobody access that
particular information who cares so
maybe they will not
notify um the
customers um but also you know you can
if you store for instance Financial
records and and and things like that I
mean third part providers might
intentionally modify data so we want to
avoid um all these
problems so provable data possession is
this area and it's a set of tools that
allow my cell phone here I'm
highlighting the cell phone because I'm
looking for um very efficient Solutions
okay so I don't want to use anything
strange or esoteric so can my cell phone
verify that the entire content of the
library Congress for instance is stored
and available
online okay so let me clarify that this
is a kind of hard problem in some sense
because once I store this information in
the cloud I don't have a local copy so
it's not like oh I have a backup and
then I can check whether the information
I have is the same as the backup stored
in the cloud now the idea here here is I
have information on my disk and I move
this information to the cloud and I just
have a disass
computer okay so I don't have this
information
anymore okay so even if I don't have
this information is it possible to
verify that everything is there so if
you store your the pictures of your
family movies and stuff can you check
that the picture you took like 30 years
ago is still there even if you don't
have a local copy okay so that's the
question we want to
answer um so the answer is yes and you
can actually do it
efficiently so before we look at some uh
solution uh let's first see some some
partial solution that might not really
work so suppose I store everything in
the cloud and I want to check if
everything is there okay one obvious way
of doing it is to retrieve this
information
okay this of course is very inefficient
because I will have to retrieve for
instance several terabytes of
data okay so another possibility will be
okay so what I'm doing is before storing
this information I'm going to compute
several Maxs on this information on this
let's say huge file and then I store
these values on my computer so I have to
store very short values and then later
when I want to check and say uh I got to
to the cloud provider and say hey um
compute this Mac on on my file and give
back this value to me and then I will
check whether that Mac is valid now this
solution actually doesn't really work
because here we are talking about a file
of several terabytes if I ask Google to
compute a Mac on 75 terabytes for
instance it will take
weeks okay so it's not a problem of the
Mac is a very efficient uh uh primitive
the problem is accessing several terab
requires um a long time okay so that's
not
good so what I could do is though I can
use a probabilistic approach um so
rather than asking for the entire file
what I could do is I can say okay look
this is a key to compute a Mac up and
you know compute a Mac on block number
one block number 10 block number 50 and
100 so I pick random file blocks and I
ask the provided to compute Max on those
okay since we are considering an
adversary that is deleting you know a
percentage of the
file um like for instance a 1% I don't
have to ask for many blocks to have a
good probability of catching a
misbehaving um a provider for instance
if I delete 1% of my
file if the cloud provider deleted 1% of
my file I can I can ask for about 500
file blocks if I want to have a
probability of catching the adversary uh
higher than
99% okay but this is not so so what the
cloud provided we do is we'll get this
file blocks or books in The Case of the
Library of Congress and compute the Mac
under the key provided by the client and
send back this books and the max
corresponding
Maxs now this solution is better
definite than the previous ones but it's
still not satisfactory first of all uh
it's linear with respect to the number
of file blocks I paed uh the cloud
provider of and also I need to just
check why do I need to get the books in
the first place or the file blocks in
the first place I mean I don't need to
have those uh just for checking I don't
need to read those books I just want to
make sure that the cloud provider is
storing those books that's it or those
file blocks okay so the question will be
can I check uh that those books are
stored without downloading the actual
books
okay so essentially using constant uh
bandwidth s I'm just a little bit
confused so the Google is Computing
you're giving the key for a MC to Google
I mean if you don't trust Google I mean
you cannot use security of a map if you
give the key you stor those before so
you computed you comped yourself I why
not just even store them oh you say
Google will refuse to store uh I mean
usually aine you can also store yeah of
course yeah if you don't have local
storage you can store it using for
instance authenticated encryption and
say oh before you compute this give me
my answers that I stored in this safe
yeah I
mean
so so so the idea here is though is that
we don't want to download books okay so
we don't want to download files I don't
need to read them in order to check if
they are stored so our Target is to kind
of um
aggregate a Max so if I have several
Maxs I want to find a way to compress
them into a single value and also I
don't want to send file blocks uh at all
so I need to be able to check this Max
which now are just a single value
without um having the actual messages
which sounds a little bit
crazy so since not so many of you are
necessarily cryptographer let me just
quickly um
um refresh memory like what about RSA
signatures because our solution will be
based on RSA um so if I have n equal to
the product of two big primes in this
particular case we are using safe primes
where P Prime Q Prime are Al are also
primes and e is a public exponent RSA D
is the secret exponent such that e * D
is congruent to one mod fi of N and and
so the public key in RSA signatures is
en n and the secret key is D and the
factorization of n so what you do in
order to sign a message in RSA you use a
a random or call H um and you U hash
your message M and raise to D mod then
and to verify the signature you
basically raise the signature to the
public
exponent okay and if you get back h of M
then the signature is valid
this is just the standard RSA signature
in the random Oracle model
okay and indeed our schemes also work u
in the random work model so so let me
look at a first um simple um solution so
suppose I have a a block uh Mi okay and
what I do is I want to compute like a
Mac or a tag on this block okay now this
Mac or this tag whatever will look like
this so H is again a random Oracle um
I'm simplifying a lot denotation so but
consider this wi as just an index I okay
so this represents the position of the
file block okay inside the file for
instance I'm considering the second file
block this will be two okay so I'm
hashing two and times G is element in
zist N with very large order and this
will be raised to the actual file block
okay and everything will be kind of
signed using RSA so I'm raising this to
D
Modine okay so imagine this is our tag
so how can I design a scheme to verify
that Mi is actually stored at Google
without knowing
Mi so what I can do is I can do this
interactive protocol so I'm asking
Google for instance hey I want to know
if you're storing my I block okay oh I
sure so um previously of course I sent
Mi to Google okay and along with the tag
TI that I competed as in the previous
slide okay so what Google will do is
we'll just send Mi and the actual tag TI
okay and then I just verified that this
tag is valid now here I'm kind of
cheating because as I mentioned before I
don't want to send the message in the
first place right so but here I'm just
sending the message and and a kind of
signature on this message
okay indeed this is just a
simplification let's look at the case
where we have many file
blocks so this is the full solution I
don't think the colors
are so suppose I have this very long
file
okay so so what I do is um I store this
file uh into the cloud provider along
with the tags okay and then I want to
check that this file is still there so I
use a probabilistic approach so I'm
going to ask for random file blocks okay
so I'm going to say to the cloud
provider hey I want to know if you're
storing my first book my third book uh
my sixth book and my seventh book okay
okay
y storage Provider from just choosing
you know the seventh book and the eighth
book in night book right so the you you
avoid this problem by using this index
here as I mentioned before in the
previous slide so if you look at this
this is actually well it's not exactly
just an index but you can assume that
this is just so this is specifies that
this is block number one and this is
block number three this is block number
six so if you change the if you use
different books this verification will
not
pass so the positions is specified
inside these
hashes um so the client says Okay I want
to know M1 uh M3 m6 and M7 okay and by
the way um I'm also sending some random
uh integer that could be small like 80
bits each okay and I'm calling this
integers A1 A3 A6 A7 they are randomly
generated for instance you can use um a
c in the random Oracle itself to
generate uh these values so you send
like a random value a random key to the
cloud provider and the cloud provider
using uses this key to generate this
integers okay so what the cloud provider
will do is we'll compute so we'll pick
all the tags T1 T3 T6 t7 that I stored
before okay and we'll compute this mod n
okay so T1 to the A1 T3 to A3 T6 A6 t7
A7 all multiplied so you can see that
this is a single value mod than okay and
then over the
integers um it's going to compute um a
function of the file blocks I was Creed
I was interested
in okay so he going to compute A1 * M1
plus A3 M3 and so so forth this is an
integer mod anything because of course
the cloud provider doesn't know the
order of the group okay which is part of
the secret key in
RSA so the cloud provider will send
these two values as you can see uh
supposed that verification works and
after the verification the idea is that
you know I can check that this file the
cloud provider is storing these files
I'm sending very short information here
right so T is a single value
uh in
this okay and this is as an integer
actually grows very slowly right it's a
sum so it grows logarithmic with respect
to the number of terms in the sum okay
so this is essentially as big as a
single
block
okay so so rather than sending a linear
number of blocks I'm just sending kind
of essentially a single
block and what I do is I I need to check
that this message is for a technicality
is say again how big are the a one yeah
I mentioned before there they could be
small they could be usually 80
bits okay so it could be 80 bits
yeah um so what I do is I verify that
practically this tags this this kind of
aggregated tag uh was computed correctly
okay okay and so what I do is I pick
whatever the cloud provider sent me I ra
I raise that to e okay and then I divide
this by um if you remember how this T
This Ti were formed right where were
like h of the index G to the file block
okay so what I'm doing essentially is I
want to remove the H part from from from
from this uh value okay okay so I'm
removing these H parts from from this
and what I'm left is G2
DM okay if this verification passes then
I can claim that those files those file
blocks were actually stored there at the
server even though I don't have these
file blocks in the first
place okay yep uh why do you have to
check that m is less than e right I mean
um it's important because um it's
actually it happens in the security
proof um if m is bigger than e you can
cheat because uh you can pick um so in
order to prove the security what you do
is uh you have this t to the E so the
simulator you know simulates the game
with the the adversary and will create
like a fake file and tags and then what
we what there is an adversary that will
come up with a forgery okay so we'll
come up with some T
Prime um such that t Prime will pass
this verification even though the files
are not there okay then if you divide t
to the E and and and this value so so
the idea is that you want to make sure
that you
get on one side of the equation this
division of T and T Prime raised to E
and the other side of the equation
something that is smaller than is so
that you can use Shamir stck uh sorry
this is slightly technical forget is
this putting any on the number of
challenges that you have to send because
the the length of them yeah I mean c is
fixed at priori C is the number of
challenges is fixed at prior is okay
yeah so n e is a very large uh prime
number yeah and by the way this works U
sorry I'm technical again but this works
when RSA e doesn't have to be
necessarily less than um n so in this
case particular e is much bigger than n
could be much bigger than n so
technically this is an extension of RSA
but it's a kind of RSA with a big
exponent
so
question so said this works constant
number of
times what goes wrong if you do too many
times oh no no no it was talking about
the number of challenges so here I'm
asking for um four challenges right
depending on the application you you may
need like 400 for instance
rather you can repeat this as it's
unbounded yep how small can a uh could a
a bit so it could be like a subset no
this has have to be like 80
bits why uh because um in the end what
you do what you want to prove is that
you want to prove that if there is a
cheating adversary you can extract the
actual file okay so what you do is you
you you there is an extractor that um
query the adversary without rewinding
several times until he gets like a a
series of of uh equations that are
lineally independent then you solve the
equations and then you get the messages
back but I guess I mean you can use a
better guess as long
as okay so so the features of the scheme
is well first of all there's a nice side
effect here um I don't know if you
noticed that so if the client um can
check that these file blocks are
actually stored there without having the
file itself which is great right then
everybody can do it I mean even if I'm
not the data owner I don't have any idea
of Mis but even the data owner didn't
have doesn't have any idea of M okay so
actually this provides what we call
public
verifiability okay so everybody can
actually check that for instance Google
is storing the library Congress even
though we have no idea what the Library
of Congress is storing uh in Google okay
so everybody can do it so that's a great
um feat feature that has found many many
many applications I should mention that
after this work I think we counted like
60 Publications after that and and on
this area so it's
becoming uh quite uh interesting and
popular um another feature is that
um there's an abundant number of
challenges of course you can apply this
challenge faces um as many times as you
want I'm emphasizing this because
previous Solutions provideed just a
limited number of
challenges and also previous Solutions
required this data to be encrypted okay
we don't have to necessarily encrypt
data it could be just public data yep
I'm confused by your latest statement
so public verifiability yeah because uh
I could do the same game
with the the another library and and get
the same proof what would distinguish it
and say this is the Library of Congress
that I'm
checking well yeah I mean remember that
this public the public the RSA public
parameters are given to you by the
library Congress so the library Congress
is saying yes you are the taxpayers so
this is e and N uh please you know once
every two weeks checks that uh check
that Google is storing everything for us
you know so so the idea now people are
using this to in order to Outsource uh
this verification type of thing because
now you can everybody can check so even
an auditor can check that those files
are stored there even though the auditor
has no idea what this data is about and
think about like liability and financial
records sometimes you know um
institutions are they have to
necessarily Outsource have an auditor
that can check that this financial stems
are stored correctly and nobody's
modifying them but for privacy reasons
before a certain uh date they cannot be
released so you want to provide also
some some form of privacy protection yep
so would be to say an abstract way uh to
get efficiency for seconds the libr of
Congress publish post uh public
verification key and basically it gives
to the Google a signed copy of of
whatever information
want and then basically what Google does
it basically proves the Cs proves to
everybody that it knows side me right
and since it don't know you can do but
remember that here we are talking about
a very large file so when you do this
proofs right but it doesn't give the Cs
proof so it's it's efficiently
verifiable it's short and it's you know
right but the problem is know a side
message and since this is sign this is
this use PCP right I mean aside from
using PCP and in a sense it's more
efficient of course but in conceptu
right because the problem is that you
don't want to access the whole file
unfortunately when you want to
prove proof you don't access the whole
file right because uh you basically you
know it's a has tree and you give one
random P you don't access the whole
thing yeah but you you pay like
logarithmic uh right but here is
essentially
constant
okay yeah I mean also one thing we want
to emphasize is that we wanted to look
at something that was you know
essentially constant in size so independ
yeah so if you apply to the files you
can make sure to detect let's say a 1%
loss of data if you line below the ECC
layer can you do better and make sure
that that the data cannot be lost
because yeah I mean again uh for
efficiency reasons here we are just uh
focusing on
detecting um uh corruption or percentage
of the files okay it if you want to
recover your data that's a different
problem uh you can apply U error
correction codes of course but then it
becomes less practical for several
reasons in particular uh we also are
interested in Dynamic data see here I
was talking about archival storage now
this is kind of static you can only add
data you can never delete information
okay and these Protocols are using error
correction code are fine as long as the
data is static but if you want to change
F blocks if you want to have the ability
to have to modify your picture your
picture that you stored three years ago
you want to apply like some filtering
something and then store the new version
of the of the picture then becomes
extremely complicated and inefficient if
you use Arrow correction
codes what's the underl assumptions from
RSA yes it's RSA but in the random
Oracle model I was argued before that
the random Oracle doesn't exist I think
it's debatable because you can always
think of like a remote
server uh that computes the hash for you
so somehow but yeah I mean
unfortunately but we do have some some
some results in
it no no it's standard R say yes but you
guys have a follow up which
may maybe yeah we have U yeah this is
the paper I wanted to mention here well
first um I want to mention that um if
you don't care about um abundant number
of
challenges and uh if you don't care
about public
verifiability uh then together with um
Jin sudik and and and and researchers in
Rome um we found a very extremely
efficient way of doing this
uh that it's extremely fast and uses
only hash functions okay so the the the
intuition I'm not going to go into
details but the intuition there is you
kind of precompute all the responses
that you would expect from from Google
or any cloud provider and you store this
uh Google itself uh in crypto using for
instance authenticated
encryption okay so we have this uh very
efficient solution so so so the the
complexity comes from the fact that uh
we are interested also in public key
verifiability and and and um of the P
solution the public verifiability the
abundant number of challenges but we may
argue that you don't really need an
abundant number of challenges
anyway um in recent work in the in the
with here at Microsoft s Kamar and
Jonathan cats uh we actually find a a
generic way of
transforming um what we call kind of
homomorphic Sigma protocols these are
kind of Sigma protocols that have a
certain homomorphic property into pdps
and this transformation doesn't use um
random
oracles um however um we need a random
orle for the actual construction but
thanks to this compiler now we can pick
any kind of Sigma protocol as long as
they satisfy this homomorphic property
and build a PDP for instance we we built
uh a PDP based on factoring so it turns
out that this is as efficient as the RSA
version so this shows the benefit of of
of this compiler just to check the
compiler builds the pp without random I
mean whe use random oracles so so the
transformation doesn't use any random
Oracle at all but it build just
Aggregates Sigma yeah but then the
actual um the actual Sigma protocol
might require the ROM
Oracle so the so in this result for
instance we started from a sigma
protocol that has this homomorphic
properties but that uses the random
Oracle and then we apply our compiler so
in the end we had to rely on the random
mole but it's an interesting opening
question to start from a sigma protocol
with theomorphic properity that works in
the standard model okay we haven't um
found any not protocol do not have this
Y what is the technical difference
between proofs of data possession and
pro of
reability um yeah there are two kind of
slightly dis you can see uh proof of
retrievability as PDP so this technique
applied to a file where it's encoded
using error correction code or eraser
codes I mean this is a very rough
equivalent but it's not exactly
that St most yeah I mean suppose my file
is encoded using error correction code
first before I apply the PDP scheme on
it okay then of course um if I want to
retrieve files right I I retrieve the
you know the good ones and then I I
recover the bad ones from the using the
error correction code so but that's a
rough equality I mean there are
distinctions very subtle
distinctions we can talk offline but
more or less it's a PDP using eraser
codes first so you you encode your file
and then you apply the
P the nameability
I mean it's a different for instance we
don't care about retrievability so I
don't want to prove that my scheme
satisfies the retrievability property I
just care about detection mostly because
of efficiency we focus on more efficient
schemes okay so let me quickly focus on
on the other interesting primitive I
think it's very important for cloud um
crypto in general aoxy re encryption so
which provides a way to um yep question
um so how does this relate to the model
of R from from the morning could these
things be used this this yeah that was
the question so so
um it's basically p is basically PDP
plus eras your codes more or less I
mean just to see it
uh so PP if you lose a block you lose
for good but in if you lose a block you
mightet
it
yeah so what is proxy re
encryption um and why is it useful um
for the cloud so proxy encryption
basically is the following so suppose I
have a message encrypted for Alice okay
I would like to have this server so so
this encrypt this encrypted email goes
to the mail server right the mail server
forwards this to to to Ellis so suppose
Ellis goes on vacation and she says she
asks Bob to to read her emails while
she's
away okay so ideally we would like to
have like a mail server okay that gets
this encrypted email under Alis public
key decrypted okay and re-encrypt this
information using Bob's public
key okay so that would be a solution um
the problem with the solution though is
that the mail server first has to know
the secret key of
Lis
okay and so the mail server will see the
actual
message okay so that's not um a
satisfiable
solution so in proxy re encryption what
we want to do is the following we want
to find a way to provide some proxy key
to the mail server okay that is used to
translate between encryptions so I think
of proxy encryption is a way to
translate between different languages so
this is encrypted a message encrypted
for Alis and this is the translator and
it can translate something that only Bob
can
understand okay now the nice thing of
proxy re encryption is that from this
information I provide to the proxy
there's really no way to recover the
message okay so the proxy doesn't have
to know the secret ke
vales okay and at the same time would
not be able to actually read the message
so that that that's that's the ideal
solution now this concept was introduced
in
98 at eurocrypt 98 by Blaze blammer and
and Strauss and they provided a very
basic protocol for um let's say
algal
okay so basically the idea is very
simple um suppose Alis as public key G
to the A
okay and Bob has probably key G to
theb so in order to encrypt using a gal
what I can do is I pick a message m in
the same group generated by G and I
multiply M by G to the r where R Is
Random so G has to be a group of prime
order so R is chosen in the Q where Q is
this Prime
order okay and then I also release G Tod
R A this is actually a very a variant of
of algal but it's
equivalent and I want to come up with
something that will allow me to go from
here right which is an encryption for
Alice to here which is an encryption for
Bob okay one way they they say that they
do it is by releasing B ided by a mod Q
okay where Q is this prime
number so clear C the proxy knows B ID
by a so it doesn't know A or B okay
doesn't know the secret key and the
proxy can raise this to B over a to
actually get
grb so it will copy the first message
entirely okay and it will compute this
operation on the second component of
alal so if this was a proper encryption
for Ellis this is also a proper
encryption for
B okay well there are several issues
with this problem though uh first of all
it's bir
directional so it means that if Ellis
goes on
vacation
okay um and the proxy has this key of
course encryption for Alis can be
transformed into encryption for Bob but
also the other way around so encryption
for Bob can be transformed into
encryption for a remember that this is
mod q a q is prime so every element does
an inverse
um another problem is that the secret
key requires interaction so in order to
generate B divided by a I need both Bob
and Alice to be online and
participate and if one of the two
actually collude with the
proxy can get the others uh secret key
which is really kind of bad and also
transitivity if I have if the proxy has
several keys for instance from Ellis to
Bob and Bob to Charles then the proxy
itself without even interacting with the
users can generate a key for Alice to
Charles even though they may not know
each other functionality right if I have
a to B I can transform a side Forex to b
side Vex and no you may want something
like a to the B and then you have B to
thec but not necessarily you have a
relationship a to the C you have it no
but you have right because uh uh A to B
and B to C let you transform aex to C
seex which is exactly the functionality
of ageny right yeah yeah I mean in
principle yes but you can find the um
versions of this protocol where you can
actually not do it this so you can say I
want an encrypt I want to be able to do
from a to the B and from B to the C but
I don't necessarily want a to d c I
don't want the transitivity property and
you can actually achieve
that so this property may be good for
some application but actually bad for
others are you saying you know the
Transformations from a to be be some
kind of
specialer if you do it yeah
unfortunately yeah I mean all these
Solutions have like what we call first
and second level of encryption that are
distinct yeah it's kind of asymmetric um
the
protocol
so well of course it's a big area
we we also defined um the security of
the schemes and um in order to solve
this problem which seems hard we kind of
used the magic one in cryptography the
Balin maps and since they were
introduced before so I don't have to
introduce them here so we use a a balina
map e and we use a symmetric uh map from
G1 G1 to G2 and we publish uh as before
as like in algal G2 the A and G2 theb as
the public keys of Alis and Bob and we
publish Z which is the value of the
generator of G2 which is called the the
ex the extended field and we encrypt
messages in the the extension field
M uh G2
sorry so so here comes the asymmetry we
were mentioned before so suppose I want
to encrypt a message for Alice such that
the proxy cannot translate so only Alis
can read this encryptions okay so just
compute like standard algal but now in
G2 okay so M ZK
ZKA and this is just standard alamala
just remove a and divide this ZK ZK and
get M
back suppose now in instead I want to
encrypt a message for Alice so that
Alice can read it of
course but if she's on vacation is she
she has delegated someone
else okay then the proxy can translate
it and the idea is that now we send mzk
and
gka okay where G now is a generator of
G1 not the extension field anymore and
now we provide to the proxy this key GB
ided by a now notice that b divided by a
is in the exponent okay so informally
it's protected it's not available
anymore to the
proxy okay and
also notice that in order to compute
this GB divided by a bob doesn't have to
be online at all it's not an interactive
scheme anymore because I can start from
the public key of Bob G2 DB which is
available by definition
okay so we solved like two three
problems at the same time and then very
simply what you can do
is um in order to transform this
encryption for a into an encryption for
Bob the proxy will just compute the
pairing of gka and GB / a and you get
exactly
zkb which is of course a properly formed
ALG encryption for B now okay there are
interesting a lot of interesting
protocols here but let me mention why
this is useful in the cloud
scenario
um these actually I think are Kevin
slides right
um so so we have uh different clients
and we want to use um um a storage
provided right so we want to encrypt all
these files
um as it works right now
suppose these clients have to share
files okay suppose we have Google Docs
that are encrypted okay and we want to
share these
files um current solutions to this
problem would require like what is
called the key server okay so the key
server encrypts all these files okay and
then if I want to access a certain file
I will have to ask for the key to the
key server and say hey can I
decrypt uh this file okay and the key
server will say well let me see if you
have access rights to this file I will
ask the owner if I should provide you
with this
information okay and this works pretty
well the only problem here is that we
have to trust the key server the key
server in principle could read all the
files because the key server owns the
actual
Keys okay but these are the current
Solutions and also the server is always
online is also a single point of attack
okay so if you compromise the key server
you get all the
keys so how can I use proxy re
encryption here well it's very simple
you have a
question can we go back to the
prox
back back yeah so looks like there are
two ways to encrypt for if I want to
encrypt something to dog I can either
use Z or I can use little G and these
two are different encryption mechanisms
yes so if you apply the same decryption
algorithm you won't get the same message
so how do I know what the right message
is and what no the message is always the
same and the first part of of the
encryption doesn't change what changes
is the second
part
so it's the decryption algorith that is
uh different in one case and the
other but the message is always the same
what is
the this case in the first seconde
for okay so in the first case it's just
a plain um elgamal so what you do is you
remove your circuit a from the exponent
and you divide this two right and you
get M
back in the second
case you can simply compute um you can
remove the a right compute the map the
pairing so you go to you compute ZKA
right using the map and then divide ZKA
again you have to know which whether
it's in the first group or it's second
yes I mean it's implicit uh because of
course there are two distinct group
groups and you can you can specify if
this is a like a first level encryption
or a second level
encryption when you enry so the first
encryption is just for uh people that
want to send a message like to Alice and
there is no way for anybody else to to
to read this message even if there are
proxies set up by
Alice
okay the second one says well you know
if Alice delegated someone it's fine by
me the important thing is that Alice
gets the message
syntactically something is wrong because
the top line and the bottom line should
have the same syntax so I expected to
see the Z on the top line also I have
G
um well unfortunately we have this
symmetry somehow but
uh it will be an interesting problem to
find unidirectional sche because you
know consider this scheme is not
bidirectional
for instance I can only go from Alice to
Bob I cannot go
back I cannot translate encryptions from
Bob to a Alice okay but we can talk
offline um I have two minutes so I was
here I was
mentioning um so you encrypt what you do
then if you don't want to reveal your
key um to the key server what you can do
is I encrypt my
file uh using for instance the as and
CBC mode and with a symmetric key and
then I encrypt the symmetric key using
my public key and then I store this to
uh the cloud storage okay now suppose
Bob wants to access this file okay so
what I can do is I can send a re
encryption key to the cloud provider
from A to
B now what the cloud provider can do now
it's only translate so it will pick the
encryption the encrypt symmetric key and
convert the encryption from a to the B
but by the properties of proxy
encryption won't be able to learn the
underlying message so the underlying key
and won't be able to know any secret key
from Alis to
Bob
okay and so Bob will be able to decrypt
this
information and use this key to decrypt
the actual file using as symmetric
encryption okay and so this is very cool
actually a similar system
um I don't know if you remember there
was this attack on Apple iTunes in the
past I mean the problem was that they
were trying to convert an encryption
from a certain user to another user and
it was attacked because you know this
key was actually stored inside the
program if they used proxy encryption
like this way they would have avoided
this problem in the first
place um we have some recent results but
I don't going to talk about it I just
want to mention
that um one property we
we we provided recently is what we call
Key privacy for a proxy re encryption
and the idea here is that the proxy will
not learn even the participants by
looking at the proxy key okay will not
learn the identities of Alice and Bob
and these are several interesting
applications uh to conclude
um again CL cryptography um it's a great
opportunity uh for research and for the
first time I think cryptography is
really essential to the cloud provider I
mean Cloud providers will fail if they
don't provide um a way to give control
back to the users of their their own
data they will never really use uh Cloud
uh storage or Cloud providers if they
don't feel they have control on their
data so this time it seemed like crypto
can make a difference I hope I I
convince you that provable data
possession is
cool um I think proxy re encryption is
interesting in general and um it's a
good way to provide access rights in the
cloud and let me list just uh briefly
three interesting open problems uh one
is to provide a PDP with full privacy so
when I mentioned I can check uh that um
the file is stored uh on Google for
instance and I don't have to have these
files in the first place but during this
proofs I can actually leak some
information about the the the actual
file blocks it will be nice to provide
complete zero knowledge and actually she
mentioned that uh with with s and and
and Kamar and Jonathan cast we have some
results on this this
front um so now we can have full privacy
in PDP schemes uh which is related to
kind of leakage resilient um signature
schemes uh it will be nice to to to find
efficient PDP schemes for multiple
storage servers and for the proxy re
encryption part it will be nice to find
efficient unidirection and multihop
approxi encryption scheme as should
mentioned that if you use fully
homomorphic encryption you can build um
unidirectional multihop encryption
schemes so theoretically this problem is
done the the emphasis is on efficient
and possibly key private so it will it's
still open to find an efficient solution
for that
thanks for one
question hey you you are not supposed to
ask anything I have a
plan uh so it's been a while since I
thought about this but so back when I
used to write cryptographic file systems
uh
I talked with Susan I said hey Susan can
you know any constructions and symmetric
key world that can do this kind of
atomic Pro encryption um and has it been
shown now that that's impossible or or
what what what's the state no the latest
um result on this is a paper
from um agelos at
Colombia uh using this but it's a very
limited um protocol for symmetric so so
the question is can we do proxy re
encryption using symmetric primitive for
instance an encryption uh under a
certain key as for instance under a
certain key K1 and transform it into an
encryption of as under K2 what's the
role of the server
then um it's just aoxy the setting
changes quite a b doesn't it uh yeah I
mean suppose you have a symmetric
encryption and you want to transform it
from uh into an encryption under a
different
key without knowing the actual message
now there has been some work uh in the
past but nothing
really um that is uh provides all this
uh features so only for public key
cryptography somehow you can you can
find this but there's no results that
says this is not possible it looks
unlikely also because it's hard to prove
anything public key prox implies
symmetri key protion butly right no no
the question is if I have of course yeah
but then I will have to use number
Theory yeah so so so the question is is
more like not just symmetric encryption
but efficient symmetric encryption using
as or D or this symmetric ciphers it's
not even clear what impossible me right
because right exactly but yeah I mean
not using number Theory to
achieve
because so efficient uh prf or PRP so
Block ciphers in general so is it
possible to do it we don't know I mean
there is some partial results from from
these guys at
Colombia good let's thank the speaker
again
sure